christmas morning is usually a time for
families to gather honor traditions and
of course exchange gifts but for many
this christmas will look
a little different still a gallup poll
found that 93 percent of americans
are expected to celebrate christmas in
some way
today i sure hope so but in another
recent survey 60
of adults say they just feel overwhelmed
by the number of issues the country's
facing
understand that too bishop t.d jakes is
senior pastor of the potter's house
that's a 30 000 member church in dallas
welcome
and merry christmas to you bishop jakes
thank you it's a real pleasure to be
with you thank you for having me
we're so glad you're here listen i think
you're one of the most optimistic people
i know one of the smartest thinkers i
know so i think it's perfect that you're
here with us on this christmas morning
because 2020 has been a really rough
year
social people up a net economic upheaval
health upheaval yet i've heard you say
you are still optimistic and you still
have hope
please share yes i i think it's very
very important that we remain optimistic
because of the challenges that we've
faced in uh
the vicissitudes of the past year and
several years preceding it but this
year in particular has been particularly
devastating
that gives us a reason to celebrate our
own survival
that we made it through it that we're
still here
we have more reason to celebrate than we
ever had before because we've
never been as challenged as we are right
now so to celebrate that you're still
here
whether you have a lot of gifts or a few
gifts to celebrate that you have endured
and i know that there are people who
have lost
loved ones and that sort of thing and
and that's a very painful thing to go
through
but uh god still has a purpose and a
plan for your life and you have to
explore it
and live your life to the fullest that
is your gift to the people
you lost bishop you believe that the
challenges of 2020 are actually making
us
more connected than ever before how so
well we're more grateful we're more
appreciative we're more polite we've
we've learned not to take our loved ones
and our friends for granted we're
checking on each other more
we're more concerned about each other
and i think that we've gotten back to
what really matters
we were carried away with so many uh
temporal things and now we're
learning to latch on to the intangible
values of
family and love and god and life itself
bishop all this separation may make us
value
our family even more this christmas even
if we are still apart but at the same
time there is divisiveness in the
country
like we have not seen in in decades
really people can measure it they they
say the polarization is very extreme
how do we fix that in the year to come
i think it's gonna take time you know uh
whenever there's
uh a laceration healing takes time
you can't instantly heal and i think the
lacerations have been so deep
that we have to give ourselves time to
heal and we're going to heal one-on-one
we're going to heal in the elevators
we're going to heal
on the sidewalks we're going to heal in
the way that we treat people
that we can't label what we're really
upset about is
labels not people and when you actually
meet people
outside of their label you find out that
there's more to unite us than there is
to divide us
you know this is a first holiday for a
lot of people where there is that empty
chair at the table i often find that
when you lose someone
the first holidays that first year is
always the hardest because you're going
back to what it was like last year
but you say we have to get ahead of the
grief
what do you mean by that and how do you
do that
you when you see it's coming and you
know that it's going to be tough and a
certain place is going to be tough or
seed is going to be empty
change the game rearrange things break
your tradition
uh go for a ride take the family on a
ride
go skiing do something that's out of
your norm
so that you're not sitting in the misery
of yesterday you have to create a new
future and a new paradigm
for you and your family bishop because
of the holidays
uh i mean sorry because of the pandemic
uh so many people are
are having difficulty sort of trying to
figure out how to celebrate this year
i've heard that from a lot of people
it's like they need the season but in
some ways they
aren't quite sure how to embrace it and
of course a lot of people can't
be with their families which is also
very difficult how do we celebrate do
you think
i think that it has to be a myriad of
things we have to take advantage of the
technology that we
have we have to zoom and facetime and do
all of the things that we can to be
connected with people
that we're far away from but we also
have to enlarge the
understanding that being by ourselves
doesn't mean that we can't be
celebratory
to have some me time to do something for
you i think that's important also
what's your tradition of this day i know
you and you i know you and your wife
certainly have a tradition at the house
i hope it involves banana pudding i will
say that
he makes great banana pudding i hope it
involves that
yes yes everything involves food in our
culture
so there'll be plenty of food our
problem is there's more food than there
are people to eat it and that becomes a
problem but uh
my kids you know the ones that are local
we will be connected and
uh we we normally have
huge gatherings and bring all the
college kids who couldn't get home and
the people who lost loved ones and
we have huge gatherings on christmas but
this this time it'll be much smaller
it'll be just our family
but we'll still have a good time yeah i
think it's important that we figure out
a way to do that especially on this day
thank you very much bishop t.d jakes
always always a pleasure
thanks for having me god bless you guys
you too